This was not the most important speech Barack Obama gave in November. It didn't get much press coverage. In fact, it wasn't even important enough for Barack Obama to show up in person to deliver. He pre-taped a video. But for the people who saw this speech, it was a big, big deal. This was at the opening session of an international conference on global warming that had been convened in Los Angeles by Governor Arnold Schwarzenegger. Mary Nichols is in charge of creating California's climate change policies and is close to some people in the Obama camp. So she was one of the few people attending who knew that the video was on the program. Barack Obama had just been elected two weeks before.
这不是贝拉克·奥巴马在11月发表的最重要的演讲。它没有得到太多新闻报道。事实上，它甚至都不重要到需要奥巴马亲自到场发表。他预录了一段视频。但对于观看这段演讲的人来说，这是一件非常、非常重大的事情。这是在洛杉矶举行的一场关于全球变暖的国际会议的开幕式上，该会议由阿诺德·施瓦辛格州长召集。玛丽·尼科尔斯负责制定加利福尼亚州的气候变化政策，并与奥巴马阵营中的一些人关系密切。所以，她是为数不多知道节目中有这段视频的与会者之一。贝拉克·奥巴马当时才刚刚当选两周。
A lot of us were still kind of absorbing the reality that we actually were going to have a new president. And I really wasn't expecting much more than a welcome, and congratulations, and I'm so glad you're doing this, kind of message. I really wasn't expecting anything of substance. So we're in this gigantic ballroom. And there's hundreds of people from all over the world.
我们很多人还在消化我们确实要迎来一位新总统的事实。我真的没指望能听到什么实质性的内容，只觉得会是一个欢迎、祝贺，或者类似于“我很高兴你们在做这件事”的消息。我们当时身处一个巨大的宴会厅里，有来自世界各地的数百人。
--from, I believe, over 50 states, provinces, and countries.
——我相信，来自50多个州、省和国家。
This is Anthony Eggert, a senior policy adviser for the California Air Resources Board.
这位是安东尼·埃格特，加州空气资源委员会的一名高级政策顾问。
Governor Schwarzenegger basically introduced the conference, welcomed the delegates--
施瓦辛格州长基本上介绍了会议情况，欢迎了代表们——
--want to welcome you all to the Governor's Global Climate Summit. This is a historic--
——欢迎大家参加州长的全球气候峰会。这是一个历史性的——
--and then said we have a welcome message from our president-elect.
——然后说我们有一条来自当选总统的欢迎信息。
--introduce a video from our President-elect Barack Obama, just to show to you--
——介绍一段来自我们当选总统贝拉克·奥巴马的视频，只是为了展示给你们看——
And then the video comes up. There's Barack Obama just facing the camera and starting to talk.
然后视频出现了。贝拉克·奥巴马正对着镜头开始讲话。
When I heard him come on it was really shocking.
当我听到他出现时，真的很震惊。
Lucia Green-Weiskel works promoting low-carbon policies in China. And she attended the conference with the Chinese delegation.
露西娅·格林-韦斯克尔在中国推广低碳政策。她随中国代表团参加了这次会议。
Because I had been listening really carefully throughout the entire campaign about his position on climate change and frankly hadn't heard a whole lot of very specific commitments.
因为我在整个竞选期间一直在非常仔细地聆听他对气候变化的立场，坦白说，我并没有听到太多非常具体的承诺。
Yeah. It was a bit frustrating.
是的，这有点令人沮丧。
And he didn't spend a lot of time on it, from my perspective. And I wanted him to say, this is the most important thing. And he didn't say that. But then all of a sudden, he seemed to be saying that.
从我的角度来看，他并没有在这上面花太多时间。我希望他说这是最重要的事情，但他没说。但随后突然间，他似乎就在说这件事。
Few challenges facing America, and the world, are more urgent than combating climate change. The science is beyond dispute and the facts are clear.
美国乃至全球面临的挑战中，很少有比应对气候变化更紧迫的了。科学结论不容置疑，事实也非常清楚。
Did you have any reaction when he said, "the science is beyond dispute?"
当他说“科学结论不容置疑”时，你有什么反应吗？
I thought some people in the Bush White House might be like, hey, wait a minute. That's not what we were saying.
我心想布什白宫里的一些人可能会想，嘿，等等。那可不是我们之前说的那样。
In fact, everything about the way the speech was heard had to do with the last eight years and President Bush. President Bush, of course, did not acknowledge that human beings had anything to do with global warming until 2005, his second term. And even then, he didn't do much to fix the problem. In fact, his administration tried to block others from taking action. When California policymakers like Mary Nichols created regulations to curb greenhouse gases in their own state, the Bush administration went out of its way to strike down those state laws. And all of this informed how everybody in this room heard this speech.
事实上，人们听到这段演讲的方式完全与过去八年以及布什总统有关。当然，布什总统直到2005年他的第二个任期才承认人类活动与全球变暖有关。即便在那之后，他也没有采取太多措施来解决这个问题。事实上，他的政府试图阻止其他人采取行动。当像玛丽·尼科尔斯这样的加州政策制定者在州内制定法规来遏制温室气体排放时，布什政府竟特意去推翻这些州法律。这一切都影响了会议室里的每个人听这段演讲的方式。
I think there was a huge amount of pent-up frustration and anger. And now it was actually OK to say, it really is over.
我认为当时积压了大量的沮丧和愤怒。而现在，终于可以说，这一切真的结束了。
And once I take office, you can be sure that the United States will once again engage vigorously and help lead the world toward a new era of global cooperation on climate change. Now's the time to confront this challenge once and for all.
一旦我上任，你们可以肯定，美国将再次积极参与，帮助引领世界走向全球气候合作的新时代。现在是彻底解决这一挑战的时候了。
Part of what's striking about this video is he is very emphatic. He says, now is the time to confront this. He says, delay is no longer an option. Denial is no longer an option. When he was saying those things, what did you feel?
这段视频之所以引人注目，部分原因在于他非常坚定。他说，现在是面对这个问题的时候了。他说，拖延不再是一个选项。否认不再是一个选项。当他说这些话时，你有什么感觉？
Well, it was amazement. Because I never thought that I would hear someone who was the elected president of the United States saying those words.
嗯，是震惊。因为我从没想过我会听到一位美国当选总统说出这样的话。
It was pretty emotional and pretty stunning in a lot of ways. And especially in the context of being among this Chinese delegation, I felt, wow, we elected this guy. And I'm proud.
这在很多方面都相当感人，也相当令人惊叹。特别是在作为中国代表团成员的背景下，我觉得，哇，我们选出了这个人，我感到自豪。
If I remember correctly, I may have actually done a fist pump.
如果我没记错的话，我可能真的挥了一拳。
You did a fist pump to a video, a pre-taped video?
你对着一个视频，一段预录的视频挥了一拳？
I have to admit that I did, yes. Again, this was really a watershed moment in my career.
我必须承认我确实挥了，是的。再说一次，这确实是我职业生涯中的一个分水岭时刻。
As a professional, I had never felt that way. Because I've only been working as an environmentalist under Bush.
作为一名专业人士，我从未有过这种感觉。因为我只在布什政府下做过环保主义者。
There were people crying. I had tears in my eyes, too. I can't deny it.
当时有人在哭。我也热泪盈眶。我无法否认。
Really? I have to say, you're a former federal official. I mean, you're a hard-boiled government--
真的吗？我必须说，你是一位前联邦官员。我的意思是，你是个老练的政府人员——
I am. Yeah, well, I don't know how hard-boiled. But it's true. We don't do a lot of crying in public. But this was a very emotional moment. There's no question about it. It was just a ray of hope.
我是。是的，好吧，我不知道算不算老练。但这是真的。我们不在公共场合大哭。但这是一个非常感人的时刻。毫无疑问。这就像是一道希望的曙光。
We clapped. And they you have to stop really fast. Because it's a video. And he keeps talking. And then, you also want to hear what he's going to say. So it was kind of awkward applause-- very enthusiastic, but then very short.
我们鼓掌了。然后你不得不很快停下来。因为这是视频，他还在继续讲。而且你还想听他要说什么。所以那是一种尴尬的掌声——非常热情，但非常短促。
Barack Obama even laid out, in more detail than they'd ever heard, specific targets for reducing greenhouse gases.
贝拉克·奥巴马甚至比他们以往听到的更加详细地列出了减少温室气体的具体目标。
And he concluded with just kind of a simple thanks.
最后，他以简单的一声感谢结束了讲话。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And there was a pause. And then everybody just stood up and gave this standing ovation which again, is also, I guess, intriguing. Because this is a video address.
然后出现了一阵停顿。接着，每个人都站起来报以掌声，我想这也是令人好奇的。因为这是一个视频致辞。
Right. He's on videotape. He doesn't know that you're standing up and clapping.
对。他在录像带里。他不知道你们在站立鼓掌。
Exactly, exactly. But I think it was just everybody was just so enthusiastic they couldn't help themselves.
正是如此，正是如此。但我认为每个人都太热情了，以至于无法抑制自己。
All of a sudden, the world seemed like a place where countries could come together and be productive again.
突然间，世界看起来仿佛是一个各国能够团结一致、共同有所作为的地方。
In general, people who are drawn to working in the environment are not usually optimistic. They're used to thinking about all the bad things that are going to happen, and fighting for every bit of ground. So this is one of those rare opportunities. To hear somebody who has the youth and the eloquence of Obama taking on this issue so clearly and strongly was just overwhelming.
总的来说，投身于环保事业的人通常不会盲目乐观。他们习惯于思考所有即将发生的坏事，并为争取每一寸阵地而战。所以这是一个难得的机会。听到像奥巴马这样年轻且富有口才的人如此清晰而有力地承担起这个问题，让人感到心潮澎湃。
There are lots of people waiting for very specific things from Barack Obama. And since November, I think a lot of them have had moments like this one, where they realize, oh my God, this new guy really is president. And things might change. And of course, there are other people who do not welcome that change at all. And so today, the weekend before Barack Obama's inauguration as president, we have collected voices from all over the country, people talking about what's going to happen next with this new president who has raised so many hopes. Where are we heading together, you and me and everybody else in our country, after this January 20?
有很多人在等待贝拉克·奥巴马做出非常具体的事情。自11月以来，我想他们很多人都有过像这样的一刻，意识到，天哪，这个新当选的人真的是总统了。事情可能会改变。当然，也有其他人根本不欢迎这种改变。所以今天，在贝拉克·奥巴马就任总统前的周末，我们收集了来自全国各地的声音，人们谈论着这位激起了如此多希望的新总统接下来会发生什么。在1月20日之后，你、我以及我们国家的每个人，我们将共同走向何方？
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. We have many, many people speaking about this today. The show is jam packed. Stay with us.
好的，这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《这就是美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天有很多人来谈论这件事。节目内容非常丰富。请继续收听。
Act One, All Your Base are Belong to Him. So there are hundreds of thousands of Americans who aren't just getting a new president on Tuesday. People who work for the federal government, people in the military, are also getting a new boss. The newspaper Military Times did a survey of about 2,000 active-duty servicemen and women, which asked about the coming change. A third of the respondents said that they were optimistic about Barack Obama as Commander in Chief. Another third were uncertain. About 25% were pessimistic. Presented with the statement, as president, Barack Obama will have my best interests at heart, 36% agreed with the statement. 43% disagreed. President Bush, by the way, does modestly better than Barack Obama on that one. 49% agree that he is their best interests at heart, versus Obama's 36%. Reporter Peter Biello dropped in on the Pro Cuts Barber Shop in Jacksonville, North Carolina, just across the highway from the Marine Corps' Camp Lejeune. Peter talked to some of the Marines who were getting their hair trimmed.
第一幕，你们的所有基地都属于他。所以有成千上万的美国人不仅在周二迎来了一位新总统。为联邦政府工作的人、军人，也迎来了一位新老板。《军事时报》对大约2000名现役军人进行了一项调查，询问关于即将到来的变化。三分之一的受访者表示，他们对贝拉克·奥巴马担任三军统帅感到乐观。另三分之一的人表示不确定。约25%的人感到悲观。当被问及“作为总统，贝拉克·奥巴马会把我们的最大利益放在心上吗”这一陈述时，36%的人表示同意，43%的人表示不同意。顺便说一句，布什总统在这个问题上的得分比奥巴马略高。49%的人同意他把他们的最大利益放在心上，而奥巴马只有36%。记者彼得·比埃洛走访了北卡罗来纳州杰克逊维尔的Pro Cuts理发店，那就在海军陆战队勒琼营地对面。彼得与一些正在理发的陆战队员交谈。
At first, I was a little concerned. I'm very conservative in nature. My father's very conservative, as I am, but my sisters and my mothers are all about the change. So they're pretty up for it. So for a while there, it was pretty rough. Election night wasn't a good night in the family. There were a lot of arguments and stuff like that. But it was more on my part. I was upset about them voting for him. But I'm reading his book, and I'm kind of getting a better grasp of what he's really about. And it's a lot more promising than the media made it out to be. So--
起初，我有点担心。我的天性非常保守。我父亲非常保守，我也是，但我的姐妹和母亲都非常支持这种改变。所以她们很期待。所以有一段时间，情况相当艰难。选举之夜对我们家庭来说不是一个好的夜晚。有很多争吵之类的事情。但更多是因为我。我对她们投票给他感到很不高兴。但我正在读他的书，开始对他真正关心的事情有了更好的了解。这比媒体所描述的要更有前途得多。所以——
Most Marines are against him, just because of the whole Don't Ask, Don't Tell thing that's coming out. But it's his choice so I'll go with it. He's my boss, well, soon to be my boss. But I really hope he does well for us.
大多数陆战队员反对他，只是因为即将出台的“不问，不说”政策。但这是他的选择，所以我也会跟着走。他是我的老板，嗯，很快就是我的老板了。但我真心希望他能为我们做得好。
I've been to Iraq three times and Afghanistan once. I was in Afghanistan in 2002. And I was in Iraq in 2003, 2005 and 2007. And through the deployments, I've seen tons of changes, as far as our equipment. 2003, when we were over there, we had no armored vehicles. That's for the initial assault all the way up to Baghdad, no armor on anything. And 2005, we started to get armor kits put onto our existing vehicles. And when we were over there in 2007, now the vehicles are coming up armored. So they're not as cumbersome-- trying to put 5,000 pounds of armor on a vehicle that's not meant to take it. And there have been advances. I think that those will continue to happen. And I don't think that he really has-- if he cuts defense budgeting, I think that money will still flow towards those avenues. Politicians can say a lot of different things. And it just-- they don't really have as much control as they think they do.
我去过伊拉克三次，阿富汗一次。我2002年在阿富汗。2003年、2005年和2007年我在伊拉克。在部署期间，我看到了装备方面的大量变化。2003年我们在那边时，我们没有装甲车。从最初的突袭一直到巴格达，什么都没有装甲。2005年，我们开始在现有车辆上加装装甲套件。当我们2007年在那边时，车辆自带装甲了。所以它们没那么笨重了——不需要在不适合承重的车辆上加装5000磅的装甲。确实有进步。我想这些还会继续发生。我不认为他真的有——如果他削减国防预算，我认为钱仍然会流向那些途径。政客们可以讲各种不同的话。只是——他们并没有像他们认为的那样有那么大的控制力。
That was Corporal David Weiss, and before him, Corporal Courtney Godsoe, and Corey Williamson, who is a Lance Corporal, all of them in the Marine Corps. We also visited with some military people who have direct contact with policymakers and hope to be dealing with the new White House. Nancy Updike went to the office of a veterans organization called IAVA, the Iraq and Afghanistan Veterans of America. It was started by a small group of Iraq war vets back in 2004, partly to lobby for body armor and other safety equipment for deploying service members. Now they take on a range of veterans issues, and they've been fiercely opposed to some of the Bush administration's policies, though the organization is nonpartisan and it's politically diverse, with a core of active and former military service members. Here's Nancy.
那是大卫·韦斯下士，在他之前是考特尼·戈德索下士和科里·威廉姆森，他是一名一等兵，他们都是海军陆战队的。我们还走访了一些与决策者有直接接触、并希望能与新白宫打交道的军事人员。南希·厄普代克去了伊拉克和阿富汗退伍军人协会（IAVA）的办公室。该组织由一小群伊拉克战争老兵于2004年成立，部分是为了游说为部署的服役人员提供防弹衣和其他安全装备。现在他们处理一系列退伍军人问题，并且一直强烈反对布什政府的一些政策，尽管该组织是非党派的，政治立场也很多样化，核心是现役和前军事服役人员。下面是南希的报道。
Everyone inside this tiny office is under 35, for instance, Todd Bowers, the Director of Government Affairs, who's 29.
这个小办公室里的每个人都不到35岁，例如政府事务主任托德·鲍尔斯，他29岁。
I have a lot of friends that are Republicans. Myself, I'm a Republican.
我有很多共和党的朋友。我自己就是个共和党人。
Eight years ago, Todd volunteered for the McCain campaign. He's a staff sergeant with the Marine Corps Reserves. He'll be heading to Afghanistan in March. He described the extensive conversations he had with his dad--
八年前，托德自愿参加了麦凯恩的竞选活动。他是海军陆战队预备役的上士。他将于三月前往阿富汗。他描述了他与父亲进行的广泛对话——
Both my father and I tend to lean to the right.
我父亲和我都倾向于右翼。
--all through the election, right up to election night.
——整个竞选期间，一直到选举之夜。
He would say, who is this Obama guy? Like, I don't understand how this is even a competition. What's going on here? And I remember speaking to him on election night, after Obama was elected. And I called my dad, and I said, hey man, what's going on? And he said, well, I got to tell you the people have spoken. And my dad is the most right wing guy that's out there. I mean, he's got assault rifles, lifetime NRA membership. My dad hasn't been won over by any means. I'm not going to say that. But he is definitely stepping back and just going to watch now. He's not going to yell and scream.
他会说，这个奥巴马家伙是谁？我不明白这怎么能算是一场竞争。这里发生了什么？我记得选举之夜奥巴马当选后，我打电话给我父亲，我说，嘿，老爸，怎么回事？他说，好吧，我得告诉你，人民已经发言了。我父亲是那种最极右的人。我是说，他有突击步枪，还是全国步枪协会（NRA）的终身会员。我父亲绝没有被拉拢过来。我不会那么说。但他确实退后了一步，准备观望。他不再大喊大叫了。
That sounds like that's a different stance for your dad, that if it had been somebody else, he wouldn't have even given a chance to sit back and watch.
听起来这对你父亲来说是一个不同的立场，如果换成别人，他甚至不会给对方机会退后观察。
No, he definitely would be clobbering it and saying, everything's going to fall apart. It's done. Like, I can't believe this guy got elected. He's going to screw it all up. He's not doing that.
不，他绝对会猛烈抨击，说一切都要分崩离析了。完了。就像是，我不敢相信这个家伙当选了。他会把一切搞砸的。他现在没那样做。
Todd is willing to go even further than his dad. He's hopeful about the incoming administration, to his own surprise. But after two tours in Iraq, and almost two years lobbying for veterans issues, he's also got a list of things he wants to see get done fast. Number one--
托德甚至愿意比他父亲更进一步。他对自己对新政府感到希望感到惊讶。但在伊拉克执行了两次任务，并为退伍军人问题游说了近两年后，他也列出了一份他希望尽快看到完成的事情清单。第一条——
Mental health injuries. If I get shot in the field, which I have been, you put a bandage on it. And you heal from your injuries. Mental health is the same thing.
心理健康伤害。如果我在战场上中枪，就像我经历过的那样，你会包扎它。你会从伤害中痊愈。心理健康也是一样。
Todd's challenge to the Obama administration is for them to set up mandatory, face-to-face, mental health counseling for all military service members before and after deployment, by the time he gets back from his deployment in December. And mental health in the military is not just some abstract policy issue in this office. Patrick Campbell sits behind Todd, a few feet away.
托德对奥巴马政府的挑战是，在他在十二月从部署中回来之前，为所有军事服役人员建立强制性的、面对面的心理咨询。在这个办公室里，心理健康不仅仅是一个抽象的政策问题。帕特里克·坎贝尔坐在托德身后几英尺远的地方。
When I came home from Iraq, I didn't know I had a problem. And it was only after I lost a couple friends and a couple other, better friends said to me, if you don't get counseling, I'm never going to talk to you again. And since I've come home, two of my fellow service members have committed suicide.
当我从伊拉克回家时，我不知道自己有问题。直到我失去了几个朋友，其他几个更好的朋友对我讲，如果你不去咨询，我就再也不会跟你说话了。自打我回家后，我的两个战友自杀了。
Patrick is a 31-year-old combat medic with the DC National Guard, also the chief legislative counsel for IAVA. He did a yearlong stint in Iraq. He's actually been tapped to be on sick call during the inauguration for the national guardsmen who will be working security. After the inauguration, he has a big decision to make.
帕特里克是一名31岁的华盛顿特区国民警卫队战斗医务人员，也是IAVA的首席立法顾问。他在伊拉克服役了一年。他实际上已被安排在就职典礼期间负责病假处理，负责安保的国民警卫队员将接受他的服务。就职典礼后，他面临一个重大决定。
I actually have to decide if I'm going to reenlist. And if I do reenlist, I have to go back to Iraq in March.
我实际上得决定是否重新入伍。如果我重新入伍，我就必须在三月回到伊拉克。
When are you going to decide?
你打算什么时候做决定？
I'm going to wait a couple days. I've been doing a lot of praying about it, talking to family, and just waiting for the path to become clear.
我打算再等几天。我一直在为此做很多祷告，和家人交谈，只是等着道路变得清晰。
Before Patrick's possible next deployment in March, President-elect Obama will face his first major test with IAVA and other veterans organizations. He will submit a budget. Tom Tarantino is a policy associate at IAVA and a former army captain who served for 10 years, and got through college on an ROTC scholarship. Tom gets his health care through the Veterans Administration, like a lot of his friends.
在帕特里克三月可能进行的下一次部署之前，当选总统奥巴马将面临他与IAVA及其他退伍军人组织之间的第一次重大考验。他将提交一份预算。汤姆·塔兰蒂诺是IAVA的政策助理，也是一名前陆军上尉，服役了10年，并通过预备役军官训练团（ROTC）奖学金完成了大学学业。像他的许多朋友一样，汤姆通过退伍军人事务部（VA）获得医疗保健。
I have several friends who have traumatic brain injuries. And the VA is going to be dealing with a very large population of men and women who were injured very early on in their life, and are going to need not just adequate care, but they're going to need to have excellent care for maybe the next 50 or 60 years.
我有几个朋友患有创伤性脑损伤。VA将不得不处理一大群在生命早期就受伤的男女，他们需要的不仅仅是适当的护理，他们可能在未来50或60年内都需要极好的护理。
Tom wants to see Obama continue full funding for the VA. It's been fully funded for the last two years, but those are the only two years the VA has been fully funded in its entire history. But besides what the Obama administration does, Tom will be paying close attention to how they work with veterans organizations. He said he's already seeing changes from the way things worked with the Bush administration.
汤姆希望看到奥巴马继续为VA提供全额资助。过去两年它获得了全额资助，但这只是VA历史上仅有的两年获得全额资助的记录。但除了奥巴马政府所做的事情外，汤姆还将密切关注他们如何与退伍军人组织合作。他说他已经看到了与布什政府时期运作方式的不同变化。
For the last four years, it's been a fight to get anything on their agenda, on the table, get them to support anything. I can't think of one VSO-- or, I'm sorry Veteran Service Organization-- that regularly worked with the White House on any issues.
在过去的四年里，要把任何事情列入他们的议程、摆上台面、让他们支持任何事情都是一场斗争。我想不出有一个退伍军人服务组织（VSO）会定期与白宫就任何问题进行合作。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I know that the White House had called the VFW a couple times, because they were opposed to the GI bill, and tried to get the VFW to back their position. But no. I think that's one of the things that we're all-- and I think, and I would say it's a pretty safe assumption that the veteran community, the VSO community, as a whole-- we're not going to fight with the administration for the next four years. Right away, the transition team reached out to the Veteran Service Organizations, and asked, hey, who are the 35 people you guys would like to see appointed to the VA? Which, of course, we almost did a collective spit-take when we got that phone call. Like, really? God. Which is a complete 180 from the way things have been working. This administration is looking very engaged. They're hungry. They're hungry to do things, and actually get down to work, which actually far exceeded, I think, at least my expectations.
是的。我知道白宫曾几次致电海外战争退伍军人协会（VFW），因为他们反对《退伍军人权利法案》（GI Bill），并试图让VFW支持他们的立场。但没有。我认为这就是我们所有人——而且我想，我可以说这是一个相当保险的假设，即退伍军人社区、VSO社区作为一个整体——我们不打算在未来四年与政府作对。过渡团队立即联系了退伍军人服务组织，问，嘿，你们希望看到哪35个人被任命到VA？当然，当我们接到那个电话时，我们几乎集体喷了。就像，真的吗？天哪。这与以往的运作方式完全是180度的大转弯。这届政府看起来非常投入。他们很渴望。他们渴望做事，真正脚踏实地工作，这实际上远远超出了，我想，至少是我的预期。
No one is going to use cautious optimism as their campaign slogan. It lacks the inspirational grandeur of hope. It's not a crowd pleaser. But when the crowd goes home, and everyone's back to their day-to-day work and worries, cautious optimism is where people settle down and wait to see what happens.
没有人会用“谨慎乐观”作为他们的竞选口号。它缺乏“希望”那种鼓舞人心的宏大感。它无法取悦大众。但当人群散去，每个人都回到他们日常的工作和忧虑中时，“谨慎乐观”就是人们安定下来等待事情发生的地方。
Nancy Updike, from Washington DC.
南希·厄普代克，来自华盛顿特区。
Act Two, Playground Politics. About a week after the election, the kids who show up after school for homework help and writing projects at the literacy group, 826 Valencia in San Francisco, were so hyped up, still, about the elections, that one of the adults who works there suggested that maybe they should all write letters to the new president, with their questions and their advice and their thoughts, and they would publish it in a little homemade book. Well, this idea took off. And sister groups in six other cities did the same, resulting in a brand new book called Thanks and Have Fun Running the Country. We asked some of the kids to read their letters now.
第二幕，操场政治。大选后大约一周，在旧金山826 Valencia读写小组放学后赶来寻求家庭作业帮助和写作项目的孩子们，对于选举仍然非常兴奋，以至于在那里工作的一位成年人建议，也许他们都应该给新总统写信，提出他们的问题、建议和想法，他们将把这些发表在一本自制的小书里。好吧，这个主意火了。其他六个城市的姐妹组织也做了同样的事情，最终出版了一本名为《感谢并祝你执政愉快》的新书。我们现在请一些孩子来读他们的信。
Dear Barack Obama, one thing you could fix is the economy. Something happened to me. I went out to lunch at Starbucks and I wanted to buy a cup of whipped cream. And normally, it's $0.43, but now, it's $0.74. The price raised $0.31 for no reason. So you should probably try to change things like that from happening. You should keep an eye out for things like that. I wish you good luck. PS, I love whipped cream. Love, Alexis Feliciano, age nine, Brooklyn.
亲爱的贝拉克·奥巴马，你可能解决的一件事就是经济。发生了一件关于我的事情。我去星巴克吃午饭，想买一杯鲜奶油。通常情况下，它是0.43美元，但现在是0.74美元。价格无缘无故上涨了0.31美元。所以你可能应该尝试改变这种情况发生。你应该留意这样的事情。祝你好运。附：我喜欢鲜奶油。爱你的，亚历克西斯·费利西亚诺，9岁，布鲁克林。
My name's Chatham Singh. I'm nine years old. I live in Los Angeles. I want to say to President Obama that could you help my family to get house-cleaning jobs? If I were president, I would help all nations, even Hawaii. President Obama, I think you could help the world.
我叫查塔姆·辛格。我9岁。我住在洛杉矶。我想对奥巴马总统说，你能帮我的家人找到房屋清洁工作吗？如果我是总统，我会帮助所有国家，甚至夏威夷。奥巴马总统，我认为你可以帮助世界。
Hi. My name is Bushra Habbas-Nimer. And I'm eight years old. And I live in Ann Arbor, Michigan. Dear Obama, you are going to be a great president. My whole religion voted for you. I wanted to tell you that I am Arabic, and I heard that you were halfway Arabic. I think that you deserve to be the president because you are going to do smart and good stuff. From Bushra.
嗨。我叫布什拉·哈巴斯-尼默。我8岁。我住在密歇根州安阿伯市。亲爱的奥巴马，你将会成为一位伟大的总统。我的整个宗教都投票给了你。我想告诉你我是阿拉伯人，我听说你有一半是阿拉伯人。我认为你值得成为总统，因为你将会做聪明和好事。来自布什拉。
Dear President Obama, here is a list of the first 10 things you should do as president. One, fly to the White House in a helicopter. Two, walk in. Three, wipe feet. Four, walk to the Oval Office. Five, sit down in a chair. Six, put hand-sanitizer on hands. Seven, enjoy moment. Eight, get up. Nine, get in car. 10, go to the dog pound. Please enjoy your experience as president. Sincerely, Chandler Brown, age 12, Chicago.
亲爱的奥巴马总统，这是你应该作为总统做的前10件事的清单。一，乘直升机飞往白宫。二，走进去。三，擦脚。四，走到椭圆形办公室。五，坐到椅子上。六，在手上涂免洗洗手液。七，享受这一刻。八，站起来。九，上车。十，去收容所看狗。请享受你作为总统的体验。诚挚的，钱德勒·布朗，12岁，芝加哥。
Thanks to the 826 literacy groups in Brooklyn, Los Angeles, Chicago, Ann Arbor, San Francisco, and Seattle. The book, again, is Thanks and Have Fun Running the Country . You can find it at the website of McSweeney's Magazine , mcsweeneys.net. We have more of the kids reading their letters at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
感谢布鲁克林、洛杉矶、芝加哥、安阿伯、旧金山和西雅图的826读写组织。再说一遍，这本书是《感谢并祝你执政愉快》。你可以在《麦克斯威尼杂志》（McSweeney's Magazine）的网站 mcsweeneys.net 上找到它。我们网站 thisamericanlife.org 上有更多孩子们读他们信的内容。
Act Three, Lions and Lambs. When Barack Obama chose Rick Warren of Saddleback Church to give a prayer at his inauguration, gay and lesbian groups, of course, cried foul because of Warren's past remarks about homosexuality and gay marriage. But Rick Warren's constituents also got angry. Pro-life groups, like Human Life International and Operation Rescue, condemned the move. When David Brody of the Christian Broadcasting Network asked for comments, he was flooded with angry emails about Warren from Christian conservatives. Here's a call to conservative talk show host Mike Gallagher.
第三幕，狮子与羔羊。当贝拉克·奥巴马选择马鞍峰教会的里克·沃伦在就职典礼上祈祷时，同性恋团体自然大呼不公，因为沃伦过去对同性恋和同性婚姻的言论。但里克·沃伦的支持者也感到愤怒。像“人类生命国际”和“营救行动”这样的反堕胎团体谴责了这一举动。当基督教广播网的大卫·布罗迪寻求评论时，他被保守派基督徒关于沃伦的愤怒邮件淹没了。以下是保守派脱口秀主持人迈克·加拉格尔接到的一通电话。
George, you're on the Mike Gallagher Show . Hi.
乔治，你在迈克·加拉格尔节目上。嗨。
Thanks for having me on.
谢谢你邀请我。
You bet.
不用客气。
Number one, I don't expect much out of Obama. I mean, the guy's calculating. But I've got to tell you something. And I'm going to use a harsh word against Pastor Warren. I'm going to call him a hypocrite. Because I'm a conservative Christian, and for a man who stands upon a pulpit in front of many people, and sells all these books based on his core values, I just believe he's compromising them for the wrong reasons.
第一，我不对奥巴马抱有太大期望。我的意思是，这家伙很精算。但我必须告诉你一件事。我要对沃伦牧师用一个严厉的词。我要称他为伪君子。因为我是一个保守的基督徒，对于一个站在许多人面前的讲坛上，并基于他核心价值观兜售所有这些书的人，我只是认为他因为错误的理由妥协了它们。
Yep. I'm with you. I mean, personally, I wouldn't compromise in any way on the issue of life. I wouldn't give a speech at Planned Parenthood.
是的。我站在你这边。我的意思是，就我个人而言，我不会在生命问题上做任何妥协。我不会在计划生育组织发表讲话。
Back in August, Barack Obama chose as a different pastor, Dr. Joel Hunter, to give the benediction at the Democratic National Convention, and it caused a similar storm among evangelicals. Hunter is the Senior Pastor at the 12,000-member Northland Church in Florida. He's author of the book A New Kind of Conservative . And just to get this out of the way, on the hot-button issues, he is pro-life, and against gay marriage. And he said, watching the reaction to Rick Warren the last few weeks, he's definitely had a sense of deja vu.
早在八月，贝拉克·奥巴马选择了另一位牧师，乔尔·亨特博士，在民主党全国代表大会上致闭幕辞，这也引起了福音派内部类似的轩然大波。亨特是佛罗里达州拥有12,000名成员的北地教会的高级牧师。他是《一种新保守派》一书的作者。顺便提一下，在热门议题上，他是反堕胎的，反对同性婚姻。他说，看着过去几周对里克·沃伦的反应，他绝对有一种似曾相识的感觉。
Well, they were calling me a traitor. They were saying, that you are being duped, you are being used. Somehow, you are so naive, you're giving strength to those who want to end babies' lives. And this is the most radically-left presidential candidate we've ever had, and so on and so forth.
好吧，他们叫我叛徒。他们说，你被愚弄了，你被利用了。你怎么那么天真，你正在加强那些想要结束婴儿生命的人的力量。这是我们有史以来最激进的左翼总统候选人，等等等等。
And so did you end up losing parishioners over this?
所以你最终因为这件事失去了教区居民？
Absolutely. But we also ended up gaining parishioners.
当然。但我们也最终获得了教区居民。
And did you find yourself engaged in pretty heated conversations with people you're very close to?
你是否发现自己与非常亲近的人进行了相当激烈的对话？
Absolutely, absolutely. And that's the toughest part of it. Because people that I've known for years, literally just got up and walked out of the church. I have friends that I was shocked when they left. They listened to all of this stuff about Obama. And so I think many people are still frightened or very skeptical about President-elect Obama. But it was more, you're getting out of the category here. Christians are Republicans. And you're weakening our chances of winning an election.
当然，当然。这是最艰难的部分。因为我认识多年的朋友，实际上直接站起来走出了教堂。我有朋友，当他们离开时我感到震惊。他们听了所有关于奥巴马的这些言论。所以我认为许多人仍然对当选总统奥巴马感到恐惧或非常怀疑。但这更多是，你脱离了这里的类别。基督徒是共和党人。而你正在削弱我们赢得选举的机会。
What about this idea? It seems like their premise is that it's damaging for you to even talk to anybody on the other side. What do you think of that?
那这个想法怎么样？看起来他们的前提是，你甚至与另一方的人交谈都是有害的。你对此怎么看？
Well, I think that it's very harmful to our country. It's very harmful to the faith that we say we believe in. Because that kind of very narrow, very negative, very combative approach, first of all, does not give a good image to the one we represent. That was not Jesus-style. Secondly, if you're ever to make progress as a country, or even as a faith, the very ones you want to talk to are the ones who don't agree with you.
嗯，我认为这对我们国家是非常有害的。这对我们说我们信仰的信仰是非常有害的。因为那种极其狭隘、极其负面、极其好斗的方法，首先，并没有给我们所代表的信仰带来良好的形象。那不是耶稣的风格。其次，如果你想作为一个国家，甚至作为一个信仰有所进步，你想要交谈的对象恰恰就是那些不同意你观点的人。
Well, it seems like a lot of the difference in the way people see this depends on whether or not they see President-elect Obama reaching out as a cynical act or as a sincere act. And I take it that you obviously see it as a sincere act, of reaching out.
好吧，看起来人们看待这件事方式的很大差异取决于他们是否认为当选总统奥巴马的主动接触是一种愤世嫉俗的行为，还是一种真诚的行为。我假设你显然认为这是一种真诚的、主动接触的行为。
I do. Just from my time with him, this is who he is. I'm sure there's a political awareness, because he's very politically savvy. But I think this is how he sees the world. And this is how some of the rest of us see the world also.
我是这么认为的。就我与他相处的时间来看，这就是他的人。我相信这有一种政治意识，因为他非常懂政治。但我认为这就是他看待世界的方式。这也是我们其他人看待世界的方式。
Yeah, let's talk more about that. Presumably, where you're heading with this is that there would be areas of common ground. Now, I know that one area that Barack Obama has pointed out as an area of possible common ground is he says look, there are two sides here that disagree about abortion rights, but probably agree that it's a good thing to reduce the number of unwanted pregnancies that lead to abortions. And so can we work together on that? Do you think that that's something where evangelicals would be open to working together?
是的，让我们多谈谈那个。据推测，你的想法是会有共同点。现在，我知道贝拉克·奥巴马指出的一个可能的共同点领域是他说，看，这里有两方在堕胎权问题上存在分歧，但可能都同意减少导致堕胎的意外怀孕是一件好事。所以我们可以一起努力吗？你认为这是福音派愿意共同努力的事情吗？
Very much so. Very much so. There are a number of solutions to this, all the way from sex education-- including abstinence-- to contraception to supporting adoption. So absolutely. Let's work the full spectrum.
非常愿意。非常愿意。这有很多解决方案，从性教育——包括节欲——到避孕，再到支持收养。所以当然。让我们在整个范围内努力。
Now, when you talk to friends, and read around what other people are saying, what's your sense of things? President-elect Obama reached out to you, and is reaching out to Rick Warren, as a way to reach out to evangelicals partly, and say, come on, let's have this conversation, let's see what we can work together on. Is that working? To what degree is he winning some people over?
现在，当你与朋友交谈，并阅读其他人所说的话时，你有什么感觉？当选总统奥巴马主动接触你，并主动接触里克·沃伦，作为某种程度上向福音派伸出橄榄枝的方式，并说，来吧，让我们进行对话，让我们看看我们可以一起做什么。这有效吗？他在多大程度上赢得了部分人的支持？
It is working. It is working slowly. This is going to be a long-term thing. You've got to realize that there are organizations that profit from polarization. That's where they get their audience. That's where they get their money. That's where they get their popularity. And they're not just religious organizations. You can take talk radio or television shows that are made to incite battle, combat.
这有效。它正在慢慢发挥作用。这将是一件长期的事。你必须意识到有一些组织从两极分化中获利。那是他们获得观众的地方。那是他们获得金钱的地方。那是他们获得人气的地方。而他们不仅仅是宗教组织。你可以看看那些旨在煽动战斗、冲突的脱口秀广播或电视节目。
But in a way, this gets to the heart of what Barack Obama was campaigning on. He was saying, well, let's do a new kind of politics. And in a way, you're saying the same kind of thing.
但从某种意义上说，这触及了贝拉克·奥巴马竞选的核心。他说，好吧，让我们做一种新的政治。从某种意义上说，你也在说同样的事情。
Exactly. Exactly.
正是如此。正是如此。
Can I ask you, Barack Obama announced this week that he's also, in addition to Rick Warren, he's chosen an openly-gay Episcopal bishop to also give a prayer at the inauguration. What's your take on that?
我可以问你吗，贝拉克·奥巴马本周宣布，除了里克·沃伦，他还选择了一位公开的同性恋圣公会主教也在就职典礼上祈祷。你对此有何看法？
This isn't a religious service. And so I would be surprised if he didn't include a very broad spectrum of religious leaders.
这不是一场宗教仪式。所以我如果他没有包括非常广泛的宗教领袖光谱，我会感到惊讶。
And it sounds like you see that as a positive thing too.
听起来你也认为这是一件积极的事情。
Well, yeah. It's in the nature of the occasion itself. This is about our country. This isn't about who's right theologically. This is about our country and including all the citizens of our country.
嗯，是的。这是场合本身的性质。这是关于我们国家的。这不是关于神学上谁对谁错。这是关于我们的国家以及包括我们国家的所有公民。
So the picture I get from you is that I sort of picture you, and a couple people, and right now, Rick Warren, are all in the same position, dragging evangelical friends and neighbors towards the middle, and President-elect Obama dragging non-evangelicals towards the middle, all of them very reluctant, on both sides.
所以我从你那里得到的图景是，我有点把你，还有几个人，以及现在的里克·沃伦，都想象成处于同样的位置，拉着福音派的朋友和邻居走向中间，而当选总统奥巴马拉着非福音派的人走向中间，双方都非常不情愿。
Well, let me phrase it a little bit differently. I'm going to give you a different picture. There's an old saying that you could always tell the scout on a wagon train because he was the one with all the arrows in him. And I hope I'm not going out of bounds there, being politically incorrect. But anytime you try to go to new ground, anytime you try to go to territory that you've not been in before, you're going to have resistance. But there's a whole line of people behind you that are kind of hoping you make it. And I think that's what we're seeing right now. There are people who are just waiting to get permission to think that way, to get permission to love that way, to get permission to walk out their faith that way. And I think that's what our hope is, this growing constituency of people who want to be cooperative.
好吧，让我换一种说法。我要给你一张不同的图景。有一句老话，你总能一眼认出马车队里的侦察兵，因为他是那个身上插满箭的人。我希望我没有越界，变得政治不正确。但每当你试图进入新的阵地，每当你试图去你以前从未去过的领土时，你都会遇到阻力。但你身后有一整排人，他们都在希望你成功。我认为这就是我们现在所看到的。有些人只是在等待获得某种许可去那样思考，获得某种许可去那样爱，获得某种许可去那样践行他们的信仰。我认为这就是我们的希望，这个不断增长的希望合作的人群。
Dr. Joel Hunter. His book, again, is A New Kind of Conservative.
乔尔·亨特博士。再说一遍，他的书是《一种新保守派》。
Act Four, Punching the Clock in the Enthusiasm Factory. Well, over two years ago, long before the country chose Barack Obama, a company called Tigereye Design in Greenville, Ohio chose the man. The owners liked Obama as a candidate. And they approached him, and they asked if they could make buttons and posters and yard signs-- all that kind of stuff-- for the campaign, and for the campaign's online store, which opened for business the day Obama announced his candidacy.
第四幕，热情工厂的打卡上班。嗯，两年多前，在全国选择贝拉克·奥巴马很久之前，俄亥俄州格林维尔一家名为Tigereye Design的公司就选择了这个人。老板们喜欢奥巴马作为候选人。他们接触了他，询问他们是否可以为竞选活动，以及竞选活动的在线商店制作徽章、海报和庭院标牌——所有这类东西——该店在奥巴马宣布参选那天就开张了。
Well, that turned out to be a very smart business move. If Barack Obama could do for the economy what he did for Tigereye, we would all be very, very lucky in these coming years. The company has been around for decades making promotional materials, mostly for Democratic candidates and for unions. But this turned out to be way bigger than anything they had ever gotten involved in. With the inauguration a week away, they are still cranking out merch. Lisa Pollak dropped by to watch them do it.
嗯，那被证明是一个非常聪明的商业举动。如果贝拉克·奥巴马能为经济做他在Tigereye所做的事情，我们在接下来的几年里都会非常、非常幸运。该公司几十年来一直制作宣传材料，主要针对民主党候选人和工会。但这结果比他们以往参与的任何事情都要大得多。离就职典礼还有一周，他们还在加班加点生产周边产品。丽莎·波拉克顺道去看了他们工作。
This is the sound of hope. Or at least, the sound of hope being printed out on paper, cut into little circles, and stamped onto metal disks with pins on the back.
这是希望的声音。或者至少，是希望被打印在纸上、切成小圆圈，并压印到背面有别针的金属圆盘上的声音。
These buttons that you're making looks like a presidential seal?
你们制作的这些徽章看起来像是总统印章？
Yeah. These are some of our new ones. And it says, I was there, 56th Presidential Inauguration, January 20. These are all going to Washington.
是的。这些是我们的一些新产品。上面写着，我在现场，第56届总统就职典礼，1月20日。这些都要去华盛顿。
This is Lisa Bergman. She's one of about a half dozen women cranking out buttons this afternoon. They're in a room that looks more like a crowded basement workshop than a high-volume assembly line for presidential swag. The process of making the buttons is surprisingly low-tech. The workers load the button parts into the machine-- printed fronts, metal backs, clear, plastic coating-- and then they hit a foot pedal. The machine stamps the parts together, and flips the finished buttons into a box. It all happens fast, hundreds of times an hour. The only thing that changes from day to day is the button's message. And lately, even that only changes so much.
这是丽莎·伯格曼。她是今天下午赶工制作徽章的六名女性之一。她们所在的房间看起来更像是一个拥挤的地下室作坊，而不是总统周边产品的大批量装配线。制作徽章的过程技术含量出奇地低。工人们把徽章部件装入机器——打印好的正面、金属背面、透明塑料涂层——然后踩下脚踏板。机器将部件冲压在一起，并将成品徽章翻转到盒子里。这一切发生得很快，每小时数百次。每天唯一改变的就是徽章上的信息。而最近，甚至连那个也改变不多。
Truckers for Obama, Mohawks for Obama, cat lovers for Obama, bird watchers--
支持奥巴马的卡车司机，支持奥巴马的莫霍克人，支持奥巴马的猫爱好者，观鸟者——
In the last two years, Lisa and her co-workers have made more than 10 million Obama buttons. They've supplied the campaign's online store and they company's own website.
在过去的两年里，丽莎和她的同事们制作了超过1000万个奥巴马徽章。他们为竞选活动的在线商店和公司自己的网站供货。
--surfers for Obama, oil tycoons for Obama.
——支持奥巴马的冲浪者，支持奥巴马的石油大亨。
Now, wait. Did you sell any of those?
等等。你们卖出去了吗？
Oil tycoons? Not many, no. We really didn't. Motorcycles for Obama, scooters--
石油大亨？没卖出多少，没有。我们真的没有。支持奥巴马的摩托车手，滑板车——
When I ask people here to share their views on Barack Obama, the candidate, I heard everything from passionate support to complete indifference. Several people told me they supported Obama, and that that was a plus on the job. But they also said they'd have no problem making buttons for McCain.
当我在这里请人们分享他们对候选人贝拉克·奥巴马的看法时，我听到了从热情的支持到完全冷漠的一切。几个人告诉我他们支持奥巴马，而且这对工作来说是个加分项。但他们也说如果让他们为麦凯恩制作徽章，他们也没问题。
--snake lovers for Obama, totally sweet clowns for Obama, there's cheerleaders for Obama, skaters for Obama, muscle--
——支持奥巴马的蛇爱好者，支持奥巴马的完全可爱的马戏团小丑，还有支持奥巴马的啦啦队长，支持奥巴马的滑板手，肌肉——
Nobody's ever been this excited about a presidential candidate ever.
从来没有人对总统候选人如此兴奋过。
I'm in the printing room now with Justin Hemminger, the company's head of online retail and a guy who measures excitement partly through button sales.
我现在在印刷室，和贾斯汀·赫明格在一起，他是公司的在线零售主管，也是一个部分通过徽章销售来衡量兴奋度的人。
We actually used the popularity of Obama merchandise to move a lot of the other stuff that we had from previous presidential elections that was in our warehouse. We had thousands of buttons from John Kerry, Al Gore, Clinton '96. We put one Obama button in a bag of 50 buttons with all the others on there, and people would buy them. We didn't actually start doing that until after the election. Because we didn't think anybody was going to be buying any of that stuff.
我们实际上利用奥巴马周边产品的人气来促销我们仓库里以往总统选举中剩余的其他东西。我们有成千上万来自约翰·克里、阿尔·戈尔、1996年克林顿的徽章。我们把一个奥巴马徽章放进一袋50个其他人的徽章里，人们就会买。我们直到选举后才开始这样做。因为我们没想到会有人买那些东西。
Any of that stuff meaning the Kerry and Gore and--
那些东西是指克里和戈尔以及——
Anything, actually, at all, after the election. We were pretty much sure that the bottom was going to drop out on November 5. And as it turns out, that was, like, the biggest day we had all year.
实际上选举后什么都卖不动。我们几乎确信11月5日一切都要降到谷底。结果证明，那几乎是我们全年最好的一天。
Barack Obama's popularity translated into sales in all sorts of ways that caught Tigereye by surprise. When the campaign started, the company had 30 employees. But last fall, at the peak of business, it hired close to 500, many of them temps. And they were running three shifts a day. They moved to a bigger building, built a few additions, and had to get a second warehouse for packing and shipping. But after the post-election boom, orders slowed down. The new hires were mostly let go. They're down to a staff of 50 now. And even with the inauguration a week away, the office is a lot quieter than it used to be. And with the economy the way is, it could be scary to know that your livelihood is, in some ways, tied to a nation's faith in a candidate.
贝拉克·奥巴马的人气以各种让Tigereye感到惊讶的方式转化为销售额。竞选开始时，公司有30名员工。但去年秋天，业务高峰期，它雇用了近500人，其中许多是临时工。他们每天轮三班。他们搬到了更大的建筑，进行了几次扩建，并不得不租用了第二个仓库用于包装和运输。但在选举后的热潮过后，订单放缓了。新员工大多被解雇了。他们现在只有50名员工了。即使离就职典礼还有一周，办公室也比过去安静多了。而以目前的经济形势，知道自己的生计在某种程度上与国家对候选人的信任联系在一起可能会让人感到恐惧。
I'm kind of scared of the day  that I'd come and might not see his face being printed on a shirt. I mean, that might be selfish, but it is job security. And I know there's a lot of people out there who don't have a job right now.
我有点害怕有一天我会来上班，可能看不到他的脸被印在衬衫上。我的意思是，那可能很自私，但这是一种工作保障。我知道外面有很多没有工作的人。
This is Sandy Dehart. She's worked at the company five years.
这是桑迪·德哈特。她在公司工作了五年。
Do you wear the stuff?
你穿那些东西吗？
No. I work here.
不。我在这里工作。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
That means my paycheck pays my bills. I can't buy Barack Obama shirts.
这意味着我的薪水支付我的账单。我不能买贝拉克·奥巴马的衬衫。
We're not banking on this being an income source for too much longer.
我们不指望这个作为收入来源太久。
Again, Justin Hemminger.
再说一遍，贾斯汀·赫明格。
You have to expect at some point the honeymoon's going to be over. There's definitely that element like, you got elected. You told me a lot of things that you were going to do. And now it's time to work.
你必须预期在某个时候蜜月期会结束。绝对有那种元素，比如，你当选了。你告诉我很多你要做的事情。现在是工作的时候了。
Yeah, what's the button for that?
是的，那有什么徽章吗？
Yeah, exactly. It's like buying a t-shirt for a band. You buy the t-shirt of the tour that they're on. And it's the one that you want to see, because you're excited to see them. You don't buy the t-shirt of them making the record.
是的，正是如此。这就像买乐队的T恤。你买他们正在巡演的T恤。那是你想看的，因为你很兴奋能看到他们。你不会买他们制作唱片的T恤。
Justin says the company's in a transition, trying to branch out beyond political work, and expand their pool of clients. They've ridden the wave of hope, just like Barack Obama. And now, just like Obama, they have to figure out what to do next.
贾斯汀说公司正处于转型期，试图在政治工作之外寻找出路，并扩大他们的客户群。他们像贝拉克·奥巴马一样乘上了希望的浪潮。现在，就像奥巴马一样，他们必须弄清楚下一步该做什么。
Lisa Pollak is one of the producers of our show. She has sworn holy vengeance on all computers, and hers, in particular. Tigereye's website is democraticstuff.com. Coming up, a man who's been working on the Obama campaign the last, oh, 76 years. That is in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
丽莎·波拉克是我们节目的制片人之一。她发誓对所有电脑进行神圣的复仇，尤其是她自己的。Tigereye的网站是 democraticstuff.com。接下来，一个在奥巴马竞选团队工作了，哦，76年的人。那将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的一分钟后，我们的节目继续播出。
Well, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And today on our program, with just a few days before the inauguration of Barack Obama as president, we wanted to get a sense of how people are feeling around the country, about Obama and his coming presidency. And we have arrived at Act Five of our show. Act Five, On the Court with the Clock Running Down.
好的，这里是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，在贝拉克·奥巴马就任总统仅剩几天的时间里，我们想了解全国人民对奥巴马及其即将到来的总统任期的感受。我们已经来到了节目的第五幕。第五幕，在球场上，计时器在倒数。
Well, Barack Obama's transition team made it clear this week that the incoming president plans to order the closing of Guantanamo Bay Detention Camp on his first full day in office. It's also likely, they say, that he will immediately suspend the military commissions held there. These are the special courts that the military has set up in Guantanamo that have been widely criticized as being unfair to the detainees. Sarah Koenig talked to one of the lawyers currently defending a Guantanamo detainee about all this, what's going on in Guantanamo, and what should happen next.
好的，贝拉克·奥巴马的过渡团队本周明确表示，这位当选总统计划在他上任的第一个完整工作日下令关闭关塔那摩湾拘留营。他们说，他也很可能会立即暂停在那里举行的军事委员会。这些是军方在关塔那摩设立的特别法庭，被广泛批评为对被拘留者不公平。莎拉·柯尼格与一位目前正在为一名关塔那摩被拘留者辩护的律师谈到了所有这些，关塔那摩正在发生什么，以及接下来应该发生什么。
One of the first things that Bill Keebler learned when he was sent to Guantanamo as a military lawyer was that whatever he was doing there, it couldn't accurately be called practicing law.
比尔·基布勒作为一名军事律师被派往关塔那摩时学到的第一件事就是，他在那里所做的一切，都不能准确地称为从事法律工作。
Because as a lawyer, you're used to practicing law. I mean, when you make an argument, or you make a motion, you think that you're going to get a fair hearing from a judge, that the judge is going to rule based on the law and the facts. And when you realize that you are perceived as-- and the right word is, a prop in a show, or a theater performance it is frustrating.
因为作为一名律师，你习惯于从事法律工作。我的意思是，当你提出论点，或者提出动议时，你认为你会从法官那里得到公平的听证，法官会根据法律和事实做出裁决。而当你意识到你被视为——正确的词是，一场表演中的道具，或者一场戏剧表演，这令人沮丧。
Keebler doesn't relish saying things like this. He's a military man, a Navy officer, Lieutenant Commander William Keebler, not one of those lefty ACLU lawyers who's gone down to Cuba pro bono. Keebler describes himself as a conservative. He voted for President Bush twice. And when he volunteered to work as a defense attorney in the military commissions, he thought they were legitimate. But on his very first visit to Guantanamo, he began to realize how hopelessly stacked the system was against the detainees. His first client was a Saudi guy named Ghassan Abdullah al-Sharbi. al-Sharbi didn't want to be represented by Keebler, or any other lawyer, as a protest against the proceedings. He wanted to represent himself. In a regular courtroom, he'd have the right to do that. And it was Keebler's ethical duty as a lawyer to help al-Sharbi get that from the judge.
基布勒不喜欢说这些话。他是一个军人，一名海军军官，威廉·基布勒中校，不是那些去古巴做公益工作的左翼美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）律师之一。基布勒称自己为保守派。他两次投票给布什总统。当他自愿担任军事委员会的辩护律师时，他认为他们是合法的。但在他第一次访问关塔那摩时，他开始意识到这个制度对被拘留者来说是多么绝望地叠加在一起。他的第一个客户是一个名叫加桑·阿卜杜拉·谢里的沙特人。谢里不想由基布勒或任何其他律师代表，以抗议这些程序。他想代表自己。在普通的法庭上，他有权这样做。作为律师，帮助谢里从法官那里得到这一点是基布勒的道德责任。
In a regular court, or a real court, when a detainee represents himself, the judge has to go through what's called a Faretta inquiry. He basically asks the accused, or the defendant, a series of questions that are designed to ensure that he understands that he is giving up his right to counsel knowingly and voluntarily, and he understands what he's doing. And he answered all the questions perfectly. He was a fluent English speaker, very well educated, smart guy, and said all the right things. And the judge basically excused us, and said, go back and talk to Commander Keebler-- or then, Lieutenant Keebler. Make sure you know what you're doing, and come back in here. And we'll finish. And we did that. We went back in, and the judge basically said, well, you know, I find this, I find that. Ah, but I find that the rules don't let you represent yourself. So your request is denied.
在普通法庭，或者真实的法庭上，当被拘留者代表自己时，法官必须进行所谓的法雷塔（Faretta）调查。他基本上会问被告一系列问题，旨在确保他理解自己正在明知且自愿地放弃律师代理权，并且他明白自己在做什么。他完美地回答了所有问题。他是一个流利的英语使用者，受过良好教育，聪明，说了所有正确的话。法官基本上让我们退下，说，回去和基布勒中校——或者当时的中尉谈谈。确保你知道你在做什么，然后回来。我们会完成。我们那样做了。我们回去，法官基本上说，好吧，你知道，我发现了这个，我发现了那个。啊，但我发现规则不允许你代表自己。所以你的请求被拒绝了。
In other words, in the military commissions, unlike in real courts, there was a rule saying defendants could never represent themselves.
换句话说，在军事委员会，与真正的法庭不同，有一条规则说被告永远不能代表自己。
You know, the judge went through this pretend Faretta inquiry, this complete hoax that was designed to make the thing look legitimate. It was a sham. It was a show. And when realize that--
你知道，法官进行了这种假装的法雷塔调查，这种旨在让事情看起来合法的完全欺骗。这是一场骗局。这是一场表演。而当你意识到那个——
But who was the show for? Were there people in the courtroom observing who wouldn't have known the difference? I mean, was there press there?
但这表演是给谁看的？法庭里有没有观察人员不知道其中的区别？我的意思是，那里有媒体吗？
Yeah. The media was there. And the press was there.
是的。媒体在那儿。记者在那儿。
Oh, the press is there. I see. I see.
哦，媒体在那儿。我明白了。我明白了。
Sure, and they're reporting on this stuff. And from the perspective of the outside observer, it looks like something is happening that's not really happening. And that's--
当然，他们正在报道这些事情。从外部观察者的角度来看，看起来正在发生某些事情，而实际上并没有发生。那就是——
And so were you sitting there thinking, what is the judge doing? I mean--
那你当时坐在那儿想，法官在做什么？我的意思是——
I thought we were about to win the issue.
我以为我们就要赢得这个议题了。
Oh, you believed it too?
哦，你也相信了？
Yeah. I mean, I was shocked. Oh, I was snowed.
是的。我的意思是，我当时很震惊。哦，我被骗了。
Oh, really.
哦，真的。
And I was. I mean, I was snowed. And that really was, I think, the moment that just did it for me. That whole self-representation issue, or a question of forced representation, was a metaphor for the unfairness and really the hollowness of this process. That it so lacked legitimacy, that we had to basically force people to participate in it so that it would appear legitimate to the outside world.
我确实是。我的意思是，我被骗了。而那确实，我认为，是让我彻底醒悟的时刻。那个关于自我代理的问题，或者被迫代理的问题，是这个过程的不公平和真正空洞的隐喻。它如此缺乏合法性，以至于我们不得不基本上强迫人们参与其中，以便让它在外部世界看来是合法的。
A year and a half ago, Keebler got his second assignment, to defend Omar Khadr, a Canadian citizen. You might have heard about Khadr's case. It's gotten a lot of press. He was accused, among other things, of murdering an American soldier, a medic, by throwing a grenade during a firefight in Afghanistan. He was just 15 years old, and badly wounded, when he was captured.
一年半前，基布勒得到了他的第二个任务，为奥马尔·卡德尔辩护，他是一名加拿大公民。你可能听说过卡德尔的案子。它得到了很多媒体报道。他被指控，除其他事项外，在阿富汗的一次交火中投掷手榴弹谋杀了一名美国士兵，一名军医。他被俘时年仅15岁，且受了重伤。
But unlike other kids at Guantanamo, Khadr was never given special treatment, as required both by international law and Guantanamo's own rules. Instead, Keebler says, he was tortured. He was at Bagram and Guantanamo during what Keebler calls the heyday of detainee abuse in both places. Keebler thinks the government saw Omar Khadr as a potentially great source of intelligence. Khadr's father was an enthusiastic supporter of the Taliban and Al Qaeda, and they all lived in the same compound as the Bin Ladens for a while. So Khadr's American captors treated him like an adult, and that was one problem.
但与关塔那摩的其他孩子不同，卡德尔从未受到国际法和关塔那摩自身规则要求的特殊待遇。相反，基布勒说，他受到了酷刑。他当时在巴格拉姆和关塔那摩，处于基布勒所说的两个地方虐待被拘留者的全盛时期。基布勒认为政府把奥马尔·卡德尔视为潜在的伟大情报来源。卡德尔的父亲是塔利班和基地组织的狂热支持者，他们有一段时间和本·拉登一家住在同一个院子里。所以卡德尔的美国捕获者像对待成年人一样对待他，那是一个问题。
The other, says Keebler, is that he believes that almost every aspect of the government's story about Khadr's supposed crimes is not true. So in a proceeding in December, Keebler wanted to introduce photos, photos that show Khadr buried in rubble from a fallen roof at the same time the government says the grenade was thrown, which he says proves Khadr couldn't have killed that medic.
另一个，基布勒说，是他相信政府关于卡德尔所谓罪行的故事的几乎每一个方面都不是真的。所以在十二月的一次程序中，基布勒想引入照片，显示卡德尔被埋在倒塌屋顶的瓦砾中的照片，就在政府声称手榴弹被投掷的同一时间，他说这证明卡德尔不可能杀死那名军医。
I wanted to use the photographs legitimately, in connection with an argument, for why we needed a particular witness to be produced in Guantanamo Bay at trial. And I was going to use the photographs with the military judge to illustrate what this witness would say, how the photographs would fit into his testimony. I got up to make that argument, and the judge said, I don't need to see the photographs.
我想合法地使用这些照片，与一个论点联系起来，关于为什么我们需要在关塔那摩湾审判中传唤特定证人。我打算和军事法官一起使用这些照片，以说明这位证人会说什么，照片如何契合他的证词。我站起来提出那个论点时，法官说，我不需要看照片。
And then we proceeded to get into this debate, or this colloquy, about my need to use the photographs and his desire not to let me show the photographs, and his making arguments to the effect of, well, we don't know that the photographs are going to come into evidence yet. Well, that's the argument-- that's why you don't show things to a jury. But there's no jury sitting there. The only thing that's there is, there are reporters behind the bar who might see this information, and might realize this kid's been illegitimately held for the last five years. And so it's this use of quasi-legal arguments and quasi-legal rationales to basically facilitate a cover-up.
然后我们开始进行这场辩论，或者这场关于我使用照片的必要性以及他不想让我展示照片的愿望的对话，他提出的论点大概是，嗯，我们不知道这些照片是否会被采纳为证据。好吧，这就是论点——这就是为什么你不把东西展示给陪审团看的原因。但那里没有陪审团。那里只有，吧台后面有记者可能会看到这些信息，并可能意识到这个孩子在过去五年里被非法关押。所以这就是这种使用准法律论点和准法律理由来基本促进掩盖事实的做法。
And eventually, at some point, I said, Judge, can I at least look at them on my screen? Because the way the courtroom down there works, you've got screens at the podium, and screens at the individual counsel tables, and for the judge. And then when it's published, it goes up on a big screen that everybody can see. And I said, well, can I at least show it on my screen so that I can make my argument and kind of walk through the photos verbally? And he said, sure, and then realized that the photos had come up on the prosecutor's screens, and that the reporters were peering over the bar to see if they could see the photos, and quickly said, no, no, I'll just give you witness. I'll just grant the motion so you don't have to show these photographs.
最后，在某个时刻，我说，法官，我至少能在我的屏幕上看看它们吗？因为那里的法庭工作方式，讲台上有屏幕，个人律师桌上有屏幕，法官也有屏幕。然后当它发布时，它会出现在每个人都能看到的大屏幕上。我说，好吧，我至少能把它显示在我的屏幕上，这样我就可以提出我的论点并以口头方式浏览照片吗？他说，当然，然后意识到照片已经出现在检察官的屏幕上，记者们正在吧台上方窥视，看看他们是否能看到照片，并很快说，不，不，我会给你证人的。我只是批准动议，所以你不必展示这些照片。
And that prosecutors were literally stumbling all over themselves like Keystone Cops to shut off the monitor so that the press couldn't see. And the court personnel were getting up and fumbling all over themselves to unplug the monitor so the photographs didn't come up. I mean if it wasn't so consequential, it would have been farcical.
检察官真的像电影里的笨贼一样争先恐后地关掉显示器，这样媒体就看不到了。法庭工作人员也起身，笨手笨脚地拔掉显示器的插头，照片没能出现。我的意思是，如果它不是那么重要，那就成闹剧了。
For months, Keebler says, the Bush administration had been pushing these cases forward, hoping to make it impossible for the next administration to stop them. Khadr's trial is supposed to begin just six days after Obama is sworn in. And there are pretrial hearings scheduled for the days just before and after Inauguration Day. Keebler flew down to Guantanamo the morning after I spoke to him to begin preparing for his trial, even though he anticipates the new president will pull the plug on the military commissions before it can start. He's betting Barack Obama doesn't want to preside over the world's first war crimes trial of a child soldier. Still, if the Bush administration wants to keep the show going for another few days, Keebler will keep doing his job as a prop.
基布勒说，几个月来，布什政府一直在推动这些案件，希望让下届政府无法阻止它们。卡德尔的审判应该在奥巴马宣誓就职仅仅六天后开始。并且在就职日前后的几天里安排了审前听证会。基布勒在我与他交谈后的第二天早上飞往关塔那摩开始为他的审判做准备，尽管他预计新总统会在审判开始前切断军事委员会。他敢打赌贝拉克·奥巴马不想主持世界上第一次对童兵的战争罪审判。不过，如果布什政府想让这场表演再持续几天，基布勒将继续履行他作为道具的职责。
We do have to continue to go through the motions. I mean, it's unfortunate. You would hope that the outgoing administration could sort of see the handwriting on the wall and say, there's no reason to spend time and money and move dozens of people to Guantanamo and disrupt lives for the purpose of having a trial that's never going to happen. But the policymakers on that side of things have not done a very good job over the last eight years. So I don't know that they would suddenly start making intelligent decisions in the final week.
我们确实必须继续走过场。我的意思是，这很不幸。你会希望即将离任的政府能够看到墙上的文字，说，没有理由花时间和金钱，将几十人转移到关塔那摩，并为了一个永远不会发生的审判而扰乱生活。但在那方面的政策制定者在过去八年里做得不太好。所以我不知道他们是否会突然在最后一周开始做出明智的决定。
Keebler says there a lot more people in uniform than we might think who want Guantanamo and the military commissions to end, who want to get out of the business of holding and prosecuting these people, who want things to go back to normal. And it's not just defense attorneys. A handful of military prosecutors assigned to cases in Guantanamo have resigned in protest. One of them, Morris Davis, was the chief prosecutor there, and has now agreed to help in the case of Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, the so-called 9/11 mastermind. Morris said he'd testify for the defense. And just this week, Susan Crawford, a retired judge in charge of referring cases for prosecution at Guantanamo, became the first senior Bush administration official to say publicly that detainees were tortured there. It feels like the whole thing's unraveling. If Keebler could offer President Obama one piece of advice, it would be this.
基布勒说，身穿制服的人中，想要结束关塔那摩和军事委员会、想要摆脱拘留和起诉这些人的生意、想要一切回归正常的人比我们想象的要多得多。这不仅仅是辩护律师。少数被分配到关塔那摩案件的军事检察官已经辞职抗议。其中一人，莫里斯·戴维斯，曾是那里的首席检察官，现在已同意协助哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德的案件，即所谓的9/11策划者。莫里斯说他会为辩方作证。就在本周，负责关塔那摩起诉案件的退休法官苏珊·克劳福德成为第一位公开表示被拘留者在那里受到酷刑的布什政府高级官员。感觉整个事情正在瓦解。如果基布勒能给奥巴马总统一条建议，那将是：
Make a clean break as quickly as possible. There's nothing extreme or controversial about saying that we as Americans are going to provide fair trials for people in our custody accused of crimes.
尽可能快地彻底决裂。说我们作为美国人要为在我们羁押下被指控犯罪的人提供公平审判，这没什么极端或有争议的。
Barack Obama recently floated the idea that it could take a year to close Guantanamo, which annoyed a lot of human rights' advocates, including lawyers with the Center for Constitutional Rights, who wrote a recent report laying out how you could do it in three months. And even if the new president does close Guantanamo, we still don't know what he'll do about the CIA black sites, about secret prisons, about the prison at Bagram Air Force Base. There's more to Guantanamo than just Guantanamo.
贝拉克·奥巴马最近抛出了一个想法，即关闭关塔那摩可能需要一年时间，这激怒了许多人权倡导者，包括宪法权利中心的律师，他们最近写了一份报告，列出了你如何在三个月内完成它。即使新总统确实关闭了关塔那摩，我们仍然不知道他会如何处理中央情报局的黑站点、秘密监狱、巴格拉姆空军基地的监狱。关塔那摩不仅仅是关塔那摩。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show. Seven years after the creation of Guantanamo, there are still 248 prisoners there.
莎拉·柯尼格是我们节目的制片人之一。在关塔那摩创建七年后，那里仍然有248名囚犯。
Act Six, Vox Obamali. Last week at the shoeshine stand outside of Sandy's Bar in New Orleans, some guys were talking about what an Obama presidency is going to be like. And they got onto the subject of that dog that he's going to adopt for his daughters.
第六幕，Vox Obamali（奥巴马之声）。上周在新奥尔良桑迪酒吧外的擦鞋摊上，一些人正在谈论奥巴马的总统任期会是什么样子。他们谈到了他要为女儿收养的那条狗。
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: Mister Arthur, what's the dog's name?
（主体）新奥尔良男子：亚瑟先生，那条狗叫什么名字？
I don't know.
我不知道。
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: No, they don't have a dog yet. The dog hasn't made it to the show yet.
（主体）新奥尔良男子：不，他们还没养狗。那条狗还没出现在节目里。
He got it.
他得到了它。
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: But he ought to let the public name the dog. He ought to let the country name the dog. Let everybody put it, go online--
（主体）新奥尔良男子：但他应该让公众给狗起名字。他应该让全国给狗起名字。让每个人都放上去，上网——
But you know, the dog is not that important.
但你知道，狗没那么重要。
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: Well, it's important for the children.
（主体）新奥尔良男子：嗯，这对孩子们很重要。
The businesses, though, are important.
不过，生意很重要。
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: Where are we going with this country?
（主体）新奥尔良男子：我们这个国家要去向何方？
Yeah, what's going on with the country? The most powerful place--
是的，国家发生了什么？最强大的地方——
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: Is that pothole going to be at--
（主体）新奥尔良男子：那个坑洞会——
--in the world?
——在世界上？
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: --Ursuline and Robinson for the next 20 years? Is that pothole still going to be at Ursuline and Robinson for the next 20 years, or what?
（主体）新奥尔良男子：——未来20年还在乌尔苏琳和罗宾逊吗？未来20年那个坑洞还在乌尔苏琳和罗宾逊吗，还是怎样？
Well, that's not his job, though.
好吧，不过那不是他的工作。
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: Well, it trickles down from him.
（主体）新奥尔良男子：嗯，那从他那里向下传导。
That's the people who's in charge here.
那是这里负责的人。
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: All that comes from him, and it trickles down.
（主体）新奥尔良男子：所有这些都来自他，并向下传导。
That's from the mayor, up there at City Hall.
那来自市长，在那边的市政厅。
(SUBJECT) NEW ORLEANS MAN: Listen at me. That comes from the president. It trickles down to the mayor. They give them that money to take care of their cities and their states, right?
（主体）新奥尔良男子：听我说。那来自总统。它传导给市长。他们给他们钱来照顾他们的城市和州，对吧？
It's not clear exactly what people are expecting from an Obama presidency. We know from polling data that about 2/3 of all Americans say they think he's going to do a good job. 2/3 also agree that he's very likely, or at least fairly likely, to bring real change in direction to the country. 77% say they like him. All those numbers from an NBC News, Wall Street Journal poll, by the way. But to get a better sense of what people are thinking, we asked reporters all over the country to go out with microphones and talk to people. From the dozens of hours they recorded, here's some of the voices.
目前还不清楚人们到底对奥巴马的总统任期有什么期望。我们从民意调查数据中得知，大约2/3的美国人说他们认为他会做得很好。2/3的人也同意，他很有可能，或者至少相当有可能，为国家带来真正的方向改变。77%的人说他们喜欢他。顺便说一句，所有这些数字来自NBC新闻、《华尔街日报》的民意调查。但为了更好地了解人们的想法，我们要求全国各地的记者带着麦克风走出去，与人们交谈。从他们录制的数十小时录音中，这里有一些声音。
I thought this day would never come.
我以为这一天永远不会到来。
I didn't think he had a shot in Hell.
我没想到他有地狱般的胜算。
No, I never expected to see a black man be elected president.
不，我从没指望看到一个黑人当选总统。
I didn't think the country was ready for a black man.
我没想到国家准备好迎接一个黑人了。
I live in Whitesburg, Kentucky. And my name is Tommy Anderson, and I'm 18 years old.
我住在肯塔基州怀茨堡。我叫汤米·安德森，我18岁。
And what's your political affiliation, Tommy?
你是什么政治派别，汤米？
I'm registered Democrat.
我注册的是民主党。
Very good.
很好。
But you know what some people say about that? I got this friend who said that he voted Democrat but he registered Republican. And he said somehow that gives the Democrats the advantage. Kevin Howard said that. He said he just want to make the Republicans look bad, that a registered Republican voted for a Democrat. I voted for Barack Obama. I think there are people in the world that, in general, sort of are untrusting of politicians. God, it's just so hard to say some things. I mean, especially when it's someone who is black. Because there are not a lot of black people around here. And in this county, I don't know of any politician that's black. You go to the courthouse in Whitesburg and every seat is filled with a white person. I honestly think people just aren't used to that.
但你知道有些人是怎么说这个的吗？我有个朋友说他投了民主党，但他注册的是共和党。他说这不知怎么给了民主党优势。凯文·霍华德就是这么说的。他说他只是想让共和党人看起来很糟，让一个注册的共和党人投给民主党。我投给了贝拉克·奥巴马。我认为世界上有些人，总的来说，对政客不信任。天哪，说出来太难了。我的意思是，特别是当那个人是黑人的时候。因为这里没有很多黑人。在这个县，我不知道有什么黑人政客。你去怀茨堡的法院，每个座位上都坐着白人。我真心认为人们只是不习惯那样。
My name is Ice Life.
我叫Ice Life（冰之生活）。
How old are you, Ice?
你多大了，Ice？
26. I just turned 26.
26。我刚满26岁。
And what do you do for a living?
你靠什么为生？
ICE LIFE: I'm an educator and an artist. I own an educational firm, here in Oakland. I think what Obama achieved is exciting. He's been elected the first black president of the United States. I think he's also become the president of the worst thing that ever happened to black people. So he'll become leader of 2 million black men in the penitentiary. He'll become leader of police brutality.
ICE LIFE：我是一名教育家和艺术家。我在奥克兰拥有一家教育公司。我认为奥巴马取得的成就令人兴奋。他成为美国第一位黑人总统。我也认为他成为了黑人发生的最糟糕事情的总统。所以他将成为监狱里200万黑人的领袖。他将成为警察暴力的领袖。
Did you vote for him?
你投给他了吗？
Yes.
是的。
Do you feel happy about that vote?
你对那次投票感到高兴吗？
I voted for Obama because I feel like I'd be hating on him if I didn't. It's the same reason I buy DVDs from a cat at the gas station. But I didn't vote thinking I'm going to change the world with this vote. Is a black man whose father was from Africa that had a baby with a white woman from here, going to an Ivy League college, and then becoming president of the United States the same as Marcus Garvey organizing 6 million Africans around the world? Is it equivalent to Martin Luther King at 25 years old leading bus boycotts? Is it the same? And they keep playing this like that. It's not the same thing. It is not. And really what I feel bad about, man, is all the black folks who I think are going to be disappointed as time goes on. They'll be like, what's going to happen with this thing and what is he able to do?
我投给奥巴马是因为我觉得如果我不投，我就在恨他。这和我从加油站那个家伙那里买DVD的原因一样。但我投票时并没有想我要用这张选票改变世界。一个父亲来自非洲、与这里的白人女性生了孩子的黑人，去上常春藤盟校，然后成为美国总统，这和马库斯·加维在世界各地组织600万非洲人一样吗？这等同于马丁·路德·金在25岁时领导公交车抵制运动吗？是一样的吗？他们一直这样表演。这不一样。根本不是。我真正感到难过的是，伙计，所有那些我认为随着时间推移会感到失望的黑人。他们会说，这件事会发生什么，他能做什么？
My name is Jordan. I'm 17 years old. I think him being president, it makes me feel like I could do whatever. I could accomplish any goal that I set my mind to. I don't have to be like the way other people see us, as a girl in a video, or on a corner, or something.
我叫乔丹。我17岁。我认为他当总统，让我觉得我可以做任何事。我可以完成我心中设定的任何目标。我不必像其他人看我们那样，成为视频里、街角上的一个女孩，或者类似的东西。
Is he a little bit of a superhero? Or is he a man in your minds?
在他心目中，他是超级英雄吗？还是一个人？
He's a superhero man. He's a superhuman, like Chris Brown. He's a superhuman.
他是超级英雄人。他是超人，就像克里斯·布朗。他是超人。
I'm Stetson Kennedy. And I'm in Jacksonville, Florida, where I was born in 1916.
我是斯特森·肯尼迪。我1916年出生在佛罗里达州杰克逊维尔。
And you were a journalist. I think you're probably best known for going undercover with the Ku Klux Klan.
你是一位记者。我想你可能最出名的是卧底加入三K党。
Yes, I did that, and perhaps a score of other homegrown terrorist groups.
是的，我那样做了，还有大约二十个其他本土恐怖组织。
Stetson Kennedy was speaking at civil rights rallies and writing letters and signing petitions and going to civil rights meetings starting in the '30s and '40s, when Jacksonville was pretty backwards. He told me that during the 1930s, he worked on the WPA's Federal Writers Project in Jacksonville, with the writer Zora Neale Hurston.
斯特森·肯尼迪从30年代和40年代开始在民权集会上发言，写信，签名请愿，参加民权会议，当时杰克逊维尔相当落后。他告诉我，在1930年代，他在杰克逊维尔与作家佐拉·尼尔·赫斯顿一起从事公共事业振兴署（WPA）的联邦作家项目。
And one of the things she said was that it was Jacksonville that taught me I was just a little colored girl. Jacksonville was a popular meeting ground for the Ku Klux Klan, for example. Whenever the US Supreme Court would occasionally had down a ruling in support of civil rights, our Jacksonville city fathers would basically convene an executive session to overrule the Supreme Court, just as a spite measure, I suppose you'd call it. So it was very much that kind of town.
她说的一件事是，正是杰克逊维尔教会了我，我只是一个小有色人种女孩。例如，杰克逊维尔是三K党的一个流行聚集地。每当美国最高法院偶尔做出支持民权的裁决时，我们的杰克逊维尔市的头头们基本上就会召开行政会议来推翻最高法院，我想你可能会称之为一种恶意措施。所以那确实就是那种城镇。
And so what was it like when Barack Obama came to Jacksonville to campaign?
那么贝拉克·奥巴马来杰克逊维尔竞选时是什么感觉？
Yes, well, it was unbelievable. I'm still having difficulty believing it, you know? Something like 20,000 people filled the park where he made his address, Memorial Park. There were another 8,000 shuttled off to a nearby park, and stood in the mud. And the very idea that there was that many people anywhere, on the entire peninsula, supportive of the idea of not only an African American in the White House, but all the progressive policies, the democratic things he stood for, I couldn't believe my eyes and ears.
是的，好吧，难以置信。我仍然觉得难以置信，你知道吗？大约20,000人挤满了他在阵亡将士纪念公园发表讲话的公园。还有8,000人被接送到附近的公园，站在泥泞中。而整个半岛上任何地方都有这么多人支持不仅是一个非洲裔美国人进入白宫，而且支持他所代表的所有进步政策、民主理念的想法，我简直不敢相信自己的眼睛和耳朵。
What do you make of that?
你对此有何看法？
Well, I'm glad I lived so long. It was a far cry. The Obama gathering was a good antidote for all the Klan meetings which have taken place locally. And I said to myself that I started working on the Obama campaign about 1932, and worked on it ever since.
好吧，我很高兴我活了这么久。这是一个巨大的差异。奥巴马的集会是当地所有三K党会议的一个很好的解药。我对我说，我大约从1932年开始从事奥巴马的竞选活动，从那时起一直从事。
I thought of my grandfather a lot. About how he never thought he'd see a black man get this close, you know?
我常想起我的祖父。关于他从没想过他会看到一个黑人离这这么近，你知道吗？
I think it was a beautiful thing. I'm happy I saw it in my lifetime.
我认为这是一件美丽的事情。我很高兴在我的一生中看到了它。
I don't think my grandparents would quite believe it. Like the walk on the moon, they'd say, I don't think so. That really didn't happen.
我不认为我的祖父母会完全相信它。就像登月一样，他们会说，我不这样认为。那真的没发生。
I feel that we, as always, no matter who it is, need to make sure that we are praying for whoever it is that's going in to be the leader of our country. I am Katie Dullar Howard, and 41 and holding, for right now.
我觉得我们，像往常一样，无论它是谁，都需要确保我们正在为任何即将成为我们国家领导人的人祈祷。我是凯蒂·杜拉尔·霍华德，41岁，暂时就这些。
And where are you from, Katie?
你从哪里来，凯蒂？
Kingdom Come Creek, Kentucky. So I feel concerned yet optimistic. And there have been a lot of things out there floating in this world. And so I pray that I find out that those were lies and that Obama shows me something that I can be very happy and respect him with. If he tried to change this country into a country founded on Muslim issues, I fear that. And I won't deny it.
肯塔基州王国降临溪。所以我感到担忧但乐观。世界上有很多东西在漂浮。所以我祈祷我发现那些是谎言，奥巴马向我展示了一些我能非常高兴并尊重他的东西。如果他试图把这个国家变成一个建立在穆斯林议题上的国家，我担心那个。我不会否认它。
I'm Mike Comstock. And I'm 48 years old. I was originally born in Seattle, came out here after a couple years at the University of Washington, decided to go to Montana State University. I'm a software engineer at a local firm. I don't belong to any party, but I tend to strongly believe in less government, so I suppose I'd say I tend to lean conservative.
我是迈克·康斯托克。我48岁。我最初出生在西雅图，在华盛顿大学待了几年后来到这里，决定去蒙大拿州立大学。我是当地一家公司的软件工程师。我不属于任何政党，但我倾向于强烈相信更少的政府，所以我猜我会说我倾向于保守。
Man, we're in for a tough next three or four years. Even now, we see the Israelis invading Gaza, and Barack hasn't said anything in a week. And people are worried, like, this is making you look bad. You don't even have an opinion on the subject. And already, there's investigations. What, Bill Richardson stepped down yesterday. There's still the Rezko thing. There's already scandals. And the guy hasn't even been sworn into office.
伙计，我们要经历艰难的未来三四年。即使现在，我们看到以色列人入侵加沙，贝拉克一周内什么都没说。人们担心，这让你看起来很糟糕。你甚至对这个主题没有意见。而且已经有调查了。什么，比尔·理查森昨天辞职了。还有雷兹科那件事。已经有丑闻了。而这家伙甚至还没宣誓就职。
So to me, these are big red flags. I'm going, oh my gosh, this is scary. Now, to the average person, they're going, oh, but look, here's pictures of him on the beach in Hawaii. And he's so inspirational. And the press just loves him. He must be a great guy. Could be. But we'll see how long that love affair really lasts.
所以对我来说，这些都是大红旗。我心想，哦天哪，这太可怕了。现在，对于普通人，他们心想，哦，但看，这是他在夏威夷海滩上的照片。他是如此鼓舞人心。媒体就是爱他。他一定是个好人。可能是。但我们将看看那段恋情到底能持续多久。
Well, it wasn't my choice to have it go like it did.
好吧，这不是我的选择让它像那样发生。
And I keep hearing different, different, different. But the cabinet he's putting together doesn't look very different to me. It looks very old school.
我一直听到不同、不同、不同。但我看到的他组建的内阁对我来说看起来不太不同。看起来非常老派。
When, in political discourse, have we assumed that someone who emerged from Chicago politics was a great guy?
在政治话语中，我们什么时候假设过一个从芝加哥政治中脱颖而出的人是个好人？
I don't see him pulling troops. As far as I'm concerned, they could come home tomorrow. I don't have big hopes. And I don't have any fears, because I think it's going to be exactly what it's always been.
我看不到他撤军。就我而言，他们明天就可以回家。我没有大的希望。我没有任何恐惧，因为我认为它会完全像它一直以来的那样。
I'm Adam Marsh. I'm with a company called Empire Capital Partners.
我是亚当·马什。我来自一家名为Empire Capital Partners的公司。
My name is Thomas Graff. I'm a vice president at Northmark Capital.
我叫托马斯·格拉夫。我是Northmark Capital的副总裁。
I would consider myself to be a left-leaning Republican.
我会认为自己是一个左倾的共和党人。
And what about you, Tom?
那你呢，汤姆？
I'm a Republican. I think the Wall Street people behind the scenes are scared to death. I think that as the government continues to take over the economy, there's a wholesale takeover of the private sector, a plan that Obama has-- we're going to have a --
我是共和党人。我认为幕后的华尔街人吓死了。我认为随着政府继续接管经济，这是一场对私营部门的大规模接管，奥巴马有一个计划——我们将有一个——
I'll tell you.
我告诉你。
--government owning a substantial portion of major industries? Is that what's going to come as an outcome of this?
——政府拥有主要产业的很大一部分？这就是这将带来的结果吗？
What's going to happen in its place, is it's going to go back to more of the way, I would imagine, the World War II generation lived-- living within your means, being able to put 30, 40% down on a house, buying a home only when you can afford a home.
取而代之的是，它将回到我所想象的二战一代人的生活方式——量入为出，能够在房子上付30%到40%的首付，只有在你负担得起时才买房。
That's in and of itself a scary thought. Because that whole generation was one week away from being out on the street. There was no safety net. There was no savings. Are we going back to that?
这本身就是一个可怕的想法。因为那整代人离流落街头只有一周之遥。没有安全网。没有储蓄。我们要回到那样吗？
Well, but is it a safe method also where middle America's been living on their credit cards, and their home equity? And so I think that everybody will be re-conditioned from the highest earners to the lowest earners in terms of being able to live within your means. Look, I've got a--
好吧，但这也是一种安全的方法吗，美国中部一直在靠信用卡和房屋净值生活？所以我认为每个人都将被重新塑造，从收入最高者到收入最低者，以便能够量入为出。看，我有一个——
That's a scary thought that the government is going to try to condition us. That in and of itself is socialistic Orwellian type of speak that's scaring me now.
这是一个可怕的想法，政府要试着塑造我们。这本身就是社会主义的奥威尔式的言论，现在吓坏了我。
But he's--
但他——
I'm scared that they're going to condition me to want to drive a hybrid, that they're going to condition me to use organic toilet paper.
我害怕他们会塑造我让我想要开混合动力车，他们会塑造我让我用有机卫生纸。
Next year, they're going to make you hand out eco-friendly candy, too, on trick or treat. Of course, I know you wouldn't normally give candy out to kids, but--
明年，他们还会让你在不给糖就捣蛋时分发环保糖果。当然，我知道你通常不会给孩子们糖果，但是——
With all due respect, Adam is saying, basically, if I recall correctly, he said, people should live within their means and not spend money they don't have, I believe is what he was saying. And you're taking issue with that.
恕我直言，亚当正在说，基本上，如果我没记错的话，他说，人们应该量入为出，不要花他们没有的钱，我相信那就是他说的。而你在反对这一点。
Yeah, I don't think there's anything wrong with using credit. There's no fun in living within your means.
是的，我不认为使用信用有什么错。量入为出没什么乐趣。
Look, we're going into, I believe-- and again, it's just one person's view-- I believe we're in unchartered territory. We're in a pretty dark, in a pretty bad place. And how could you not root for somebody, Democratic, Republican, how could you root against a president?
看，我们正在进入，我相信——再说一遍，这只是一个人的观点——我相信我们处于未知领域。我们处于一个相当黑暗、相当糟糕的地方。你怎么能不为一个总统加油呢，民主党、共和党，你怎么能反对一个总统？
My name's Jack Halsted. I'm a 64-year-old, well, I guess I could say, retired. I have a very small social security allotment that I'm trying to learn to live on. I voted for Obama. And I've been learning how to belch the president-elect's name. Now, there are two ways I can do it. I can either say Barack with one belch and Obama with another. Or if I really dig deep, I can say both words--
我叫杰克·哈尔斯特德。我是一个64岁，嗯，我猜我可以说是，退休人员。我有一小笔社会保障拨款，我正在努力学着靠它生活。我投给了奥巴马。我一直在学怎么用打嗝的方式发出当选总统的名字。现在，我有两种方式可以做到。我可以要么用一个嗝说“贝拉克”，用另一个说“奥巴马”。或者如果我真的深入挖掘，我可以一次说出两个词——
I want to go for both words. The whole word.
我想两个词都说。整个词。
All right. [BREATHING] I'm close. Don't distract me with your laughter. [INHALES] Barack Obama.
好吧。（呼吸）我快成功了。别用你的笑声分散我的注意力。（吸气）贝拉克·奥巴马。
Maybe we could get him in for three terms.
也许我们能让他连任三届。
He did it, he did it, he did it. I was just so proud of him.
他做到了，他做到了，他做到了。我只是为他感到如此自豪。
How do I feel about him? I love him. I just love him. I really, really, really love him.
我对他感觉如何？我爱他。我只是爱他。我真的、真的、真的爱他。
The interviews for our Vox Obamali were conducted by Davy Rothbart in Central Michigan, Barrett Golding of Hearing Voices in Helena, Montana, Mia Frederick in WMMT in Eastern Kentucky, Glynn Washington of snapjudgmentradio.org in Oakland, California, Katie Reckdahl and Eve Abrams in New Orleans, Michael Olson in Austin, Texas, and Bryan Parras with Nuestra Palabra in Houston.
Vox Obamali（奥巴马之声）的采访由戴维·罗斯巴特在中密歇根州、海伦娜的蒙大拿州“聆听声音”的巴雷特·戈尔丁、肯塔基州东部WMMT的米娅·弗雷德里克、加利福尼亚州奥克兰snapjudgmentradio.org的格林·华盛顿、新奥尔良的凯蒂·雷克达尔和伊芙·亚伯拉罕、德克萨斯州奥斯汀的迈克尔·奥尔森，以及休斯顿Nuestra Palabra的布莱恩·帕拉斯进行。
Well, our inaugural show was produced by Alex Blumberg and me, with Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Andy Dixon and P.J. Vogt. Today is our very last show with our very capable intern P.J. Vogt, who we are very sorry to see go. P.J., we all wish you the best. Seth Lind is our production manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好的，我们的开幕节目由亚历克斯·布伦伯格和我制作，简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。安迪·迪克森和P.J.沃格特提供制作帮助。今天是我们的实习生P.J.沃格特最后一天节目，我们非常遗憾看到他离开。P.J.，我们都祝你一切顺利。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。杰西卡·霍珀提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who told me that he heard that Barack Obama is going to quadruple the size of public radio. And he has a good source for that. Torey has a totally good source.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。《这就是美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他告诉我他听说贝拉克·奥巴马将把公共广播的规模扩大四倍。而且他有可靠的消息来源。托里有一个完全可靠的消息来源。
Kevin Howard said that.
凯文·霍华德就是那么说的。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《这就是美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。